changes is right as the song goes the
leadership of britain's government
changed hands this morning with a
familiar ceremony in a very unfamiliar
place you could say the new prime
minister her name is liz trust met with
queen elizabeth at her country home in
scotland usually the handover takes
place at buckingham palace it followed a
farewell from boris johnson who handed
his resignation to the queen earlier in
the day
elizabeth palmer's in london outside the
houses of parliament elizabeth good
morning that david bowie song is a good
choice big changes indeed in the uk
hello
i'll say and we saw boris johnson first
thing this morning give his goodbye
speech and yes it was delivered with a
dash of that inimitable johnsonian color
let me say that i am now like one of
those booster rockets
that has fulfilled its function and i
will now be gently re-entering the
atmosphere and splashing down
invisibly in some remote and obscure
corner of the pacific well not quite
after all he is a sitting member of
britain's parliament but he did formally
hand off to the incoming prime minister
and i will be supporting liz truss and
the new government every step of the way
in spite of the scandals that plagued
his time in office johnson has plenty of
supporters but he leaves a country
bitterly divided by brexit we can get
brexit done now his controversial
project to lead the uk out of the
european union
more recently he's very publicly
supported ukraine and committed nearly
four billion dollars in military and
humanitarian assistance at a time when
britain is facing huge economic problems
the economy will be the first challenge
for new prime minister liz truss and i
also want to thank
our outgoing leader my friend boris
johnson arguably
he also left a poisoned chalice russia
has cut off gas supplies to europe
sending energy prices rocketing up at a
time of soaring inflation
but in her acceptance speech truss did
her best to sound upbeat
i will deliver a bold plan to cut taxes
and grow our economy
liz trust got the leader's job because
she was voted in by her party but among
voters polls show she is unpopular
prime minister trust will be back in
london this afternoon to start work
it was a break with tradition as you
mentioned for the prime ministers to go
to scotland to see the queen normally
that transfer of power takes place here
in london at buckingham palace but the
queen is elderly her health is frail and
so she stayed right where she was on
vacation in balmoral and made the prime
ministers come to her tony
yeah she's got a tough job ahead liz
palmer for us in london liz thank you
very much uh we heard boris johnson at
the beginning of that piece talk about
how he's he's a booster rocket having
served his function he's gonna splash
down somewhere in the pacific a remote
and obscure corner of the pacific given
the problems in the uk right now i might
want to splash down somewhere far away
as well yeah but then you hear liz
palmer say he left behind a poison
chalice that never sounds good that is
not good it's not how i like my chalice
but we'll be watching liz trust